hey guys today we're gonna talk about
something quite interesting the
relationship between vitamin b3 and your
stomach acid now I've done a lot of
videos on stomach acid and acid reflux
and the gallbladder and digestion and
I've also recommended that you take
outside a vinegar or betaine
hydrochloride to help you with low
stomach acid which is very common but I
haven't talked about vitamin b3 helping
that condition so let's first start out
with talking about what are the symptoms
when you don't have enough acid in your
stomach first of all you're not going to
absorb minerals that well so you might
be deficient in iron or calcium or any
of the minerals okay number two
decreased amino acid absorption this can
show up in many things from hair loss to
loose skin to an incomplete digestion of
protein that causes gas okay next one
leaky gut which can lead to allergies
then we get probably the most common one
which is just bloating in general or
even abdominal pain and acid reflux SIBO
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
occurs as well when you have low stomach
acid and that's where you have bacteria
growing in the wrong place it's growing
in the small intestine not too large and
every time you consume anything with
fiber it gets worse you can't consume a
lot of salad for example without being
bloated also if you take probiotics it
makes it worse because it's not
necessarily you have all bad bacteria in
your small intestine could be good
bacteria it's just over growing in the
wrong place and these microbes are
eating up all all your nutrition so
you're going to usually have nutritional
deficiencies just from that alone and
you can also have an infection lower in
the digestive tract because the purpose
of hydrochloric acid one big purpose is
to kill off the pathogens so they don't
go through the stomach into the small
intestine to the large intestine so you
can have an infection down there and
that can create an immune problem and
lead to all sorts of issues constipation
and even diarrhea because you're not
able to digest
properly gallbladder sluggishness so
your gallbladder doesn't release and you
always feel bloated on the right side
and you're getting problems with the
digestion of fat so these are all the
symptoms that can occur when you don't
have hydrochloric acid now you can
actually take betaine how to chloride
outside a vinegar to improve the acidity
in your stomach even by the way fasting
improves hydrochloric acid I'm drinking
coffee will do it but vitamin b3 niacin
will help you make more stomach acid so
if you're deficient in b3 the common
symptoms would be depression anxiety
fatigue skin problems in diarrhea but
think about it b3 is involved in over
300 enzymes in your body it's like a
cofactor it's a helper to make these
enzymes there's a lot of things that
happen with vitamin b3 but if you have a
subclinical deficiency so you have b3
but it's just not enough but the body
will use b3 in a certain priority system
okay so it might handle your depression
and anxiety and fatigue and prevent
diarrhea but it might not be able to
make hydrochloric acid because the body
might not consider how to chloric acid
production as the priority and these
take over so if you're deficient in b3
you may not have all of the deficiency
symptoms just a few but there's a
condition called b3 dependency okay and
basically what that is is this your body
just needs more b3 okay whether it's
stress causing this or certain microbes
that are depleting your reserve these
two can be underlying causes of why you
just basically need more p3 so it can be
a subclinical thing or just basically
the stresses causing you to need more of
it and when you're under stress your
body uses up the adrenaline it oxidizes
adrenaline and b3 is very necessary to
replenish adrenaline also you have
another source of B 3 which is
tryptophan tryptophan can convert to B 3
so let's say for example you don't have
enough HCl to even help you absorb
tryptophan
this might not occur so there are
reasons that go beyond just a lack of
dietary b3 okay so you just might need
more because your body's really stressed
out
b3 is necessary in the production of ATP
which is the energy currency of the
mitochondria in the stomach cells and
these stomach cells make hydrochloric
acid so if you don't have enough b3 and
your cells can't make enough
hydrochloric acid you will start
experiencing some of these symptoms
right here maybe not these but these
over here so you watch my video and I
tell you to drink outside a vinegar and
it doesn't work well guess what you need
b3 okay so if you suspect having this
I'm gonna recommend taking a higher dose
between 50 and 100 milligrams per day
some people that are really stressed
need to take this three times a day to
see the change if you're in the
situation and you have some of these
symptoms you don't feel like your
stomach's quite right you have stomach
troubles and you're already doing all
the other things that I'm recommending
you may want to take niacin okay in this
amount right here and see if this is the
reason why you have that problem all
right
comment below and let me know what
happens thanks for watching
so if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications daily
notifications that sounds weird well
I'll just remind you on a daily basis
how about that